Sarah kommt vor 37 Jahren
in Sri Lanka zur Welt.
Mit einem Monat wird sie von einem
Schweizer Ehepaar adoptiert.
Lange interessiert sie sich nicht
für ihre Herkunft.
Doch dann, nach und nach,
wächst ihr Wunsch,
nach ihren Wurzeln zu suchen.
Dieser Prozess
hat sich über die Jahre entwickelt.
Es fühlt sich an wie kleine Nadeln,
die dich immer wieder stechen.
Aber du weisst gar nicht genau,
warum es dich schmerzt.
Ich bin Hebamme von Beruf und
habe schon so viele Geburten erlebt.
So viele Male war ich dabei
bei diesem magischen Moment,
wenn eine Mutter
ihr Baby in die Arme schliesst.
Ich hatte diese Erfahrung nie,
niemand konnte mir von diesem
emotionalen Moment erzählen.
C'est ton album
avec les photos de classe.
Immer stärker wird ihr bewusst,
dass etwas fehlt -
umso mehr, als die Beziehung
zu ihren Adoptiveltern schwierig ist.
Erst als sie selbst
eine Familie gründet,
findet sie die Kraft,
sich ihrer Vergangenheit zu stellen.
Durch die Sicherheit, die mir mein
Mann und meine Kinder gegeben haben,
konnte ich
meinen Schutzschild fallen lassen.
Ich wollte unbedingt herausfinden,
woher ich komme.
Und auch die Kinder haben begonnen,
mir Fragen zu stellen:
"Mama, wo ist meine Grossmutter,
hast du Brüder und Schwestern?",
und ich hatte keine Antwort.
Sarah weiss nichts über
ihre leibliche Mutter aus Sri Lanka -
auch nicht,
weshalb sie Sarah verlassen hat.
Von ihren ersten Lebenswochen
hat Sarah nur ein Schwarz-Weiss-Foto,
und sie ist sich nicht einmal sicher,
ob das Baby auf dem Bild
wirklich sie selbst ist.
Im März 2017 macht sich Sarah
auf die Suche nach ihren Wurzeln.
Doch die Reise
entpuppt sich als Albtraum.
Sie findet heraus,
dass ihre Papiere gefälscht sind.
In Sri Lanka existiert sie nicht.
In diesem Armenviertel von Colombo
findet Sarah schliesslich die Adresse
der Frau, die als Mutter auf ihrer
Geburtsurkunde eingetragen ist.
Im Dezember 2017
klopft sie bei ihr an die Tür.
Als wir ankamen,
war die ganze Familie im Haus.
Wir erklärten, weshalb wir da waren,
dass wir diese Frau suchen würden.
Sie kam und zeigte uns ihren Pass.
Sie sagte: "Ja, das bin ich."
Und dann sagte sie mir:
"Aber ich bin nicht deine Mama."
Dennoch fühlt sich Sarah wohl
mit der warmherzigen Frau.
Sie ist sicher,
dass es ihre Mutter ist,
dass sie es jedoch
vor ihrer Familie nicht zugeben will.
Ich konnte es nicht glauben
und sagte:
"Ich möchte einen DNA-Test
machen lassen."
Sie war einverstanden
und kam mit mir in ein Labor,
wo man ihr Blut nahm für den Test.
Ich suchte auf den Fotos
nach Ähnlichkeiten -
die Augen, die Nase,
die Stirn, der Mund.
Ich wollte glauben,
dass sie meine Mutter ist.
Auch damit ich aufhören konnte,
meine Familie zu suchen.
Als ich zurück in der Schweiz war,
lag das Resultat des Tests vor:
Sie ist mit 100%iger Sicherheit
nicht meine leibliche Mutter.
Die Frau gibt zu:
Sie hat sich vor Gericht
als Sarahs Mutter ausgegeben.
Damals gab ihr eine Frau,
die sie nicht kannte,
einige Hundert Dollar,
damit sie die Papiere unterschrieb.
Sarahs Mutter
hatte sie nie getroffen.
Im ersten Moment dachte ich,
ich müsse akzeptieren,
dass ich meine Familie
niemals finden würde.
Ich war eine Woche lang
wirklich krank.
Und da war dieser Schmerz
in meinem Körper drin.
Ich begriff,
wie tief diese Verletzung ist.
Genau wie Sarah sucht auch Olivia
in Sri Lanka nach ihrer Familie.
Die beiden haben sich
dank eines DNA-Tests kennengelernt.
Er hat ergeben,
dass sie entfernte Cousinen sind.
Ich darf nicht hinsehen.
- Deswegen sage ich es ja.
Das war ein glücklicher Zufall.
Wir sind beide
in derselben Kultur aufgewachsen,
sprechen die gleiche Sprache,
deshalb sind wir uns nahe.
Wenn du gar nichts
über deine Blutsverwandten weisst,
dann denkst du irgendwann,
du seist vom Himmel gefallen.
Das ist nicht rational.
Aber wenn man jemanden findet,
mit dem man blutsverwandt ist,
dann gibt einem das die Sicherheit,
dass es die eigene Familie
einmal gab
oder vielleicht immer noch gibt.
Dieses Gefühl,
von nirgendwo zu kommen,
hat Olivia in der Jugend
schwer zu schaffen gemacht.
Und dies, obschon sie
bei liebevollen Adoptiveltern
in der Umgebung von Zürich
aufgewachsen ist.
Als sie im Alter von 30 einen Artikel
über das Trauma bei Adoptionen liest,
wird ihr plötzlich klar,
was der Grund
für ihr tiefes Unwohlsein ist.
Ich erkannte mich sofort
in diesem Artikel.
Ich war schockiert. Ich lernte
in dieser Zeit so viel über mich.
Ich konnte die Scham überwinden,
die ich bis zu jenem Zeitpunkt
aufgebaut hatte.
Wieso Scham?
Weil ich immer dachte,
dass etwas mit mir nicht stimmte.
Oder dass ich eine schlechte Person
war, weil ich solche Gefühle hatte.
Und plötzlich erfuhr ich, dass es
eine Erklärung für all das gibt.
Und dass es ein natürlicher Vorgang
ist, eine natürliche Folge von dem,
was mir bei der Geburt widerfahren
ist, die Trennung und all das.
Nach dieser Einsicht hat Olivia
vor zwei Jahren den Mut gefunden,
nach Sri Lanka zu reisen,
um herauszufinden, wo sie herkommt.
Doch schnell hat sie gemerkt,
dass es keinerlei Angaben
zu ihrer Geburt gibt.
Ich ging den Informationen
auf meiner Geburtsurkunde nach:
Name meiner Mutter,
Geburtsdatum, Eintrag des Spitals,
in dem ich
zur Welt gekommen sein soll.
Ich war sogar
im Heimatdorf meiner Mutter.
Aber das waren alles Sackgassen.
Niemand konnte irgendetwas sagen
zu den Informationen, die ich hatte.
Heute weiss Olivia,
dass ihre Geburtsurkunde
gefälscht wurde -
genau wie die von Sarah.
Aber die beiden Cousinen
geben nicht auf.
Sie verlangen einen Termin
auf dem Amt in Colombo,
welches die Adoptionen verwaltet.
Dort werden
alle Originaldokumente aufbewahrt.
Wir haben nicht genug Informationen,
um etwas herausfinden zu können.
Wir haben gehofft, dass
auf der Geburtsurkunde bei Ihnen
Informationen zu finden sind,
die uns zu unseren Familien führen
könnten. Können Sie uns helfen?
Das Problem
ist die Kinderadoptionsverfügung.
Laut einem Gesetz von 1946 braucht es
eine gerichtliche Genehmigung,
um die Originaldokumente einzusehen.
D.h., im Moment kann ich
meine Geburtsurkunde nicht einsehen?
Nein, weil Sie gemäss dieser Urkunde
das Kind sind.
Die Frauen begreifen,
dass ihre Dossiers leer sind.
Also ich existiere nicht
auf dem Papier.
Wir wissen nicht, was in dieser Zeit
genau passiert ist, nein.
Ich bin vom Himmel gefallen.
Nicht vom Himmel gefallen, aber ...
Das ist so schwer, das Gefühl
zu haben, dass man nicht existiert.
Wir wurden in diesem Land geboren,
dieses Land ist ein Teil von uns.
Das ist die Verantwortung
der Eltern, richtig?
Ich weiss nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Möchtest du noch etwas sagen?
Es gibt nichts zu sagen,
ich bin schockiert.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Sarah und Olivia
gehören zu den 750 Babys,
die in den 80er-Jahren
von Schweizern adoptiert werden.
Wegen des Bürgerkriegs
ist Sri Lanka damals
ein regelrechtes Eldorado
für Adoptionen.
Insgesamt werden 11'000 Kinder
nach Europa gebracht.
Die Mehrheit der Paare
benutzt private Agenturen,
welche rasche Adoptionen anbieten,
mit der Option,
Geschlecht und Alter auszuwählen -
und auch,
wie dunkel die Hautfarbe sein darf.
Für Schweizer Paare gibt es mehrere
Möglichkeiten für die Adoption:
staatlich oder religiös geführte
Waisenhäuser -
aber mit wenigen Babys
und langen Wartezeiten.
Deshalb bieten sich
zwei private Varianten an.
In der Schweiz: Alice Honegger,
Vermittlerin aus St. Gallen.
In Sri Lanka: Dawn da Silva,
Vermittlerin in Colombo.
Beide arbeiten mit Anwälten zusammen,
welche die Adoptionen
mit falschen Müttern
amtlich beglaubigen.
Ein Netz von Vermittlern
sucht mit allen Mitteln nach Babys.
Sie durchforschen die Dörfer
und die Geburtsstationen
in einem Umkreis von mehreren Hundert
Kilometern um Colombo.
Ihr Ziel: ledige Mütter.
Manchmal werden Babys gekauft,
für mehrere Dutzend Dollar,
manchmal werden sie
den Müttern weggenommen
oder die Mütter
geben sie unter Druck ab.
Alice Honegger,
inzwischen verstorben,
hat mind. 200 Adoptionen organisiert,
hauptsächlich in die Deutschschweiz.
In der Westschweiz läuft der Kontakt
über Dawn da Silva.
Sie vermittelt mehr als 350 Kinder
in die Schweiz.
Denis und Monika Weissbrodt
sind pensioniert
und leben heute im Kanton Bern.
Als eines der wenigen Adoptiveltern-
paare erzählen sie von damals.
1985 lebt Familie Weissbrodt
in Colombier im Kanton Neuenburg.
Als Eltern von zwei Söhnen
möchten sie noch
ein Mädchen aus Sri Lanka adoptieren.
Ein befreundetes Ehepaar
kam eines Tages
mit einem Baby aus Sri Lanka an.
Es war so süss.
Da dachten wir, wir hätten auch gern
so ein kleines Mädchen.
Und dank dieses Paars
haben Sie sich mit Frau da Silva
in Verbindung gesetzt?
Genau.
Wir haben
Miss Dawn da Silva geschrieben.
Sie hat uns geantwortet,
dass das machbar sei
und dass wir, wenn wir
ein kleines Mädchen wollten,
ein Baby bekommen könnten.
Und so ging das los.
Sie müssen zehn Monate warten.
In dieser Zeit wird ihnen
dreimal ein neues Baby versprochen.
Hat Sie das nicht erstaunt?
Es war uns nicht richtig bewusst.
Wir sagten uns:
"Das sind arme Kinder."
Und wir ...
Wir haben uns
diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Ich weiss nicht.
Da Miss Dawn da Silva
ja Anwältin war,
dachten wir in der Schweiz,
dass man ihr vertrauen könne.
Wir konnten uns nicht vorstellen,
dass es da
nicht mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Aber Dawn da Silva ist keine
Anwältin, sie ist Reiseagentin.
Sie bietet ihren Kunden
ein umfassendes Paket an:
Unterkunft, Transport, Übersetzung -
und natürlich:
ein Kind zum Mitnehmen.
Sie kommt
aus einer einflussreichen Familie.
Und sie fordert Geschenke ein,
um den Prozess zu beschleunigen.
Man musste Whisky mitbringen,
dann Schreibstifte.
Und dann auch noch Schokolade,
da stand: 18 Tafeln. Und Uhren.
Wir fanden das schon seltsam,
aber wir dachten,
dort funktioniere halt alles anders.
Wir wollten natürlich,
dass alles gut abläuft,
also machten wir ihr diese Geschenke
und dachten uns,
das sei halt Teil ihrer Kultur,
ihrer Bräuche.
Sie haben Geschenke
im Wert von ungefähr 500 $ dabei.
Und noch vor der Abreise
müssen 1'500 $ überwiesen werden.
Zusammen mit dem Flugticket
beläuft sich die Adoptionssumme
auf etwa 5'000 $.
Als sie in Colombo ankommen,
werden die Weissbrodts
sofort abgeholt,
um ihr Baby in Empfang zu nehmen.
Wir haben vor einem grossen Eisentor
angehalten.
Man konnte nicht sehen,
was dahinter war.
Das Tor öffnete sich
und eine junge Frau nach der anderen
kam heraus
mit einem Baby auf dem Arm,
ganz kleine Babys,
und ein Geschwisterpaar, bei dem
die Schwester etwas grösser war.
Am Ende kam Miss Dawn
mit einem anderen Mädchen.
Sie legte uns unsere Tochter
in den Arm und sagte:
"Hier, für Sie das schönste Baby."
Und es stimmte:
Sandy war praktisch weiss
im Vergleich zu den anderen Kindern.
Sie war gut genährt.
Und ja, das war die erste Begegnung
mit unserer Tochter.
Waren das die Mütter der Babys,
die da herauskamen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Wir hatten nicht den Eindruck,
dass es die Mütter waren.
Ich dachte, dass es
Angestellte von Miss Dawn waren.
Es war klar, dass wir die Mütter
der Kinder nicht sehen sollten.
Die Weissbrodts
ziehen mit ihrem Baby ins Hotel.
Sie müssen zwei Wochen warten,
bis die Papiere bereit sind.
Eine Frau kommt ins Gericht, um die
Adoptionsurkunde zu unterzeichnen.
Glauben Sie,
dass das die Mutter von Sandy war?
Wir waren uns da ganz sicher.
Es ist uns
gar nicht in den Sinn gekommen,
dass es anders sein könnte.
Ihre Tochter Sandy
lebt heute in der Nähe von Paris
und sie wird in Kürze Mutter.
Vor fünf Jahren hat sie die Suche
nach ihrer leiblichen Mutter
aufgenommen - alleine, aus Angst
die Gefühle ihrer Adoptiveltern,
denen sie sehr nahesteht,
zu verletzen.
In Sri Lanka findet Sandy heraus,
dass sie aus einer
ausserehelichen Beziehung stammt.
Ihre Tante hat sie verkauft -
im Hinterzimmer
ihres Lebensmittelladens.
Meine biologische Familie dachte,
dass ich in Sri Lanka sei.
Das habe ich in Sri Lanka erfahren.
Denn am Tag meiner Adoption,
die im Hinterzimmer
des kleinen Ladens stattfand,
kam ein Mann und holte mich ab.
Er erledigte das Geschäftliche,
wenn man dem so sagen will.
Die Familie dachte,
dass ich bei diesem Mann lebe,
einem wohlhabenden Geschäftsmann.
Sie dachten,
dass ich es bei ihm gut haben würde.
Der Mann ist aber in Tat und Wahrheit
einer der Zulieferer
von Dawn da Silva.
Und die Adoptionsurkunde hat
eine Schauspielmutter unterzeichnet.
Ja, das ist Kinderhandel.
Das ist nicht normal.
Man darf nicht
mit Menschenleben spielen.
Damals ahnen die Weissbrodts
nichts von alledem.
Denn auf der Schweizer Botschaft
erhalten sie problemlos ein Visum
für ihr Baby.
Und das,
obschon die Schweizer Behörden
1985 bereits wissen, dass viele
Adoptivkinder dubiose Papiere haben.
Sie haben einfach nicht hingeschaut.
Von den Adoptiveltern
hat sich niemand beklagt -
weshalb also
sollten sie dem nachgehen?
In meinem Fall ist es so,
dass das Kind auf dem Foto
im sri-lankischen Pass
überhaupt nicht ähnlich aussieht
wie das Kind auf dem Foto,
auf dem meine Mutter
mich zum ersten Mal im Arm hält.
Es ist so offensichtlich,
dass ich mich schon frage:
Hat das niemand gesehen oder hat es
einfach niemanden interessiert?
Doch es gibt schon damals Hinweise.
1984 arbeitet Pedro Sutter als junger
Sozialarbeiter für Alice Honegger.
Er wird nach Colombo geschickt
und wird dort zweimal
bei der Schweizer Botschaft
vorstellig.
Denn er hat bemerkt, dass die
für die Visa zuständige Beamtin
diese auch im Zweifelsfall ausstellt.
Sie hat gesagt,
sie sei nur ausführendes Organ
vom Bundesamt für Justiz.
Wenn die Adoptionsurkunde da sei,
gebe sie das Visum.
Aber es habe auch Fälle gegeben,
in denen das Geburtsdatum
nicht übereingestimmt hat
mit der Geburtsurkunde
und der Adoptionsurkunde.
Sie habe das Visum trotzdem gegeben,
weil die Adoptiveltern
nichts dafür gekonnt hätten.
Empört über das Vorgehen
der Botschaft seines Landes
schreibt Pedro Sutter
einen sehr kritischen Bericht.
In Sri Lanka hat er Massenadoptionen
gesehen mit Scheinverfahren.
Er beschuldigt
die lokalen Vermittler,
sie würden sich bereichern,
und die Adoptiveltern,
sie würden nicht hinschauen.
Die Gesetze waren sehr offen,
sehr lasch, es gab keine Gesetze
und keine Höhe
der Adoptionsvermittlungen.
Jeder Vermittler konnte
so viel verlangen, wie er wollte,
es gab keine Limiten
und es war freier Markt.
Von daher war es
sicher unmoralisch, unethisch.
Es war einfach eine Dienstleistung
für Adoptiveltern,
die viel Geld bezahlt und
einen guten Service bekommen haben.
Insofern war es eigentlich
ein Business von beiden Seiten.
Aber es war nicht
zum Wohl der Kinder,
es war zum Wohl der Adoptiveltern.
Pedro Sutter will bei diesem Handel
nicht Mittäter sein.
Als er zurück in der Schweiz ist,
kündigt er seinen Job.
Wir versuchen, den Sohn
von Alice Honegger zu kontaktieren.
Er ist selbst adoptiert und führt
die Stiftung seiner Mutter weiter,
in diesem Haus am Zürichsee.
Rudy Honegger
antwortet uns schriftlich.
Er verteidigt
die Arbeit seiner Mutter,
gibt uns aber weder ein Interview
noch Zugang zu seinem Archiv.
Und was ist
mit den Schweizer Behörden?
Haben sie wirklich
die Augen verschlossen?
Wieso haben sie nicht interveniert?
Um das herauszufinden,
verlangen wir Zugang
zur diplomatischen Korrespondenz
der 80er-Jahre
zwischen der Schweizer Botschaft
in Sri Lanka und Bern.
Ein heikles Thema.
Zu Beginn erhalten wir
keine Einsichtserlaubnis vom Bund.
Es wird geltend gemacht,
dass bei Adoptionen
eine aussergewöhnliche Frist
von 120 Jahren gilt.
Es braucht
mehrere Wochen Verhandlungen.
Dann erhält Thierry Hartmann,
Recherche-Journalist von RTS,
eine Ausnahmeerlaubnis, um die
vertraulichen Dokumente anzuschauen.
Aber die Bedingungen
sind sehr strikt:
Es darf nichts kopiert
und nichts fotografiert werden.
Einzig Notizen vor Ort sind erlaubt.
In diesen Kartons
steckt ein gut gehütetes Geheimnis.
Die Schweizer Behörden
wussten seit Beginn der 80er-Jahre
vom Kindshandel
bei internationalen Adoptionen.
Bereits 1981 zeigt sich ein Diplomat
in Colombo beunruhigt,
Claude Ochsenbein.
Am 12. Oktober 1981 schreibt er
in seinem Dossier über Dawn da Silva:
Zwei Monate später
verständigt Claude Ochsenbein Bern.
Ein Herr Wettstein
vom Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen
antwortet ihm am 22. Dezember 1981:
Diese Weisung bringt
den Schweizer Diplomaten in Colombo
in eine unmögliche Situation:
Wenn er die vorgelegten Dokumente
zurückweist, bedeutet das,
dass die sri-lankischen Gerichte
korrupt sind.
Ausserdem wird die Botschaft
vor vollendete Tatsachen gestellt:
Die Schweizer Eltern
kommen in der Regel bereits
mit dem Baby und den sri-lankischen
Adoptionsdokumenten an.
Was also tun?
Claude Ochsenbein antwortet
dem Bundesamt für Ausländerfragen
mit einem detaillierten Bericht.
Er bemängelt,
dass die Schweizer Adoptiveltern
vor Ort Druck ausüben würden.
Er teilt sie in zwei Kategorien ein.
Am 3. Mai 1985 schreibt er:
Und dann gibt es
die andere Kategorie der Eltern.
Ein Beispiel:
Ein Arzt erklärt auf der Botschaft,
dass er 1'000 Fr. pro Tag verdient,
und deshalb
keine Zeit zu verlieren habe.
Einige Tage später reist er ab,
ganz stolz, mit seinem Baby.
Empört schreibt der Diplomat:
Bern hat keine Zeit,
auf den unmissverständlichen Bericht
des Diplomaten zu reagieren.
Eine Woche später, am 19. Mai 1982,
gelangt der Skandal
um die illegalen Adoptionen
an die Öffentlichkeit.
Die Zeitschrift "L'illustre"
veröffentlicht
einen schockierenden Bericht.
Der Artikel bezieht sich
auf die privaten Organisationen,
die Adoptionen vermitteln.
Dawn da Silva wird beschrieben als:
"eine der wichtigsten
Kinderhändlerinnen der Hauptstadt".
Weiter steht geschrieben:
"Die Kinder, die zum Verkauf stehen,
sind simple Exportprodukte,
sie werden in Massen gehalten."
"Sie sind in fünf bis sechs Heimen
untergebracht,
welche die Einwohner
Babyfarms nennen."
Gemäss der Zeitschrift
stosse das alles
bei den Schweizer Behörden
auf taube Ohren.
Für die Schweizer Zollbeamten
zähle nur,
dass die Papiere des Kindes
korrekt seien, steht da.
Das ist auch
die Linie des Bundesrats.
Im Juni 1982 erklärt Kurt Furgler,
dass es in Sri Lanka
vielleicht ein Problem gäbe
mit gewissen lokalen Vermittlern,
aber nicht in der Schweiz.
Trotz der Anschuldigungen
des Diplomaten in Colombo
und der Zeitungsartikel unternehmen
die Schweizer Behörden 1982 nichts,
um den Skandal zu stoppen
und private Adoptionen zu verbieten.
Und auch die Adoptiveltern wollen
ihren Kinderwunsch nicht aufgeben.
Mit der Hilfe von Alice Honegger
und Dawn da Silva
kommen in den folgenden vier Jahren
weiterhin
Hunderte sri-lankischer Babys
in die Schweiz.
Doch im Januar 1987
wird Dawn da Silva verhaftet.
Ihr wird vorgeworfen, ihr Hotel
in eine Babyfarm verwandelt zu haben.
Einige Monate später gibt Sri Lanka
die internationalen Adoptionen auf.
Doch es wird noch 30 Jahre dauern,
bis die Behörden im Herbst 2017
das Ausmass des Handels
in den 80er-Jahren zugeben werden.
Es gab viele solche Babyfarms.
Eine war in meinem Bezirk,
in der Nähe des Strandes.
Sie führten dort eine Razzia durch
und nahmen einige Leute fest.
In diesen Babyfarmen
haben sie Babys gesammelt
und an Ausländer verkauft
für eine Adoption.
In der Schweiz
wird Olivia und Sarah klar,
dass sie mit ihrem Schicksal
nicht allein sind.
Die meisten Kinder,
die in den 80er-Jahren
aus Sri Lanka adoptiert wurden,
haben falsche Papiere.
Sie beschliessen,
einen Verein zu gründen.
70 Adoptierte treten sofort bei.
Inzwischen sind es bereits 120.
Wir möchten das Problem
auch politisch angehen,
damit wir sicher sein können,
dass so etwas nicht wieder vorkommt.
Dass anerkannt wird,
was damals geschehen ist.
Das wäre schon sehr wichtig.
Die Schweizer Behörden
wussten Bescheid darüber,
was vor 35 Jahren geschehen ist.
Es ist nicht so,
dass sie nichts gewusst haben
oder nichts hätten wissen können.
Sie sagten sich wohl:
"Gut, die Adoptiveltern
haben ihr Baby bekommen,
alle sind zufrieden",
und haben nicht weitergedacht.
Die Schweiz muss
diese Verantwortung auch tragen,
sie kann nicht einfach alles auf das
Geburtsland der Babys abschieben.
Ihr Aufruf wird gehört,
auch im Bundesrat.
Er hat ein Postulat angenommen,
welches zum Ziel hat,
Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen
bei den Adoptionen aus Sri Lanka.
Das Bundesamt für Justiz
hat zwei Jahre Zeit,
um einen Bericht zu erstellen.
Wir haben ganz klar die Aufgabe,
die adoptierten Kinder
zu unterstützen
bei der Suche nach ihren Wurzeln.
Diese Aufgabe
steht in der Verfassung.
In diesem Zusammenhang
stellt sich die Frage,
ob es zu Rechtswidrigkeiten oder
Unregelmässigkeiten gekommen ist.
Und in der Folge zu entscheiden,
was man damit macht,
oder was man
noch zusätzlich machen kann.
Die Adoptierten aus dem Verein
haben klare Erwartungen.
Sie verlangen u.a.
psychologische Unterstützung
und finanzielle Hilfe des Bundes
für die Suche nach ihren Wurzeln.
Doch die Dinge gehen langsam voran -
das Dossier hat in Bundesbern
keine hohe Priorität.
Wir haben keine zusätzlichen Mittel,
kein zusätzliches Personal bekommen,
um den Bericht zu verfassen.
Die Behörde für Adoptionen
ist sehr knapp bemessen.
Wir sind drei Personen,
von denen sich momentan keine
voll diesem Dossier widmen kann.
Nathalie ist mit ihrem älteren Bruder
adoptiert worden.
Sie hat 2001 mit der Unterstützung
ihrer Adoptiveltern
eine Frau gefunden,
von der sie glaubt,
dass sie ihre Mutter ist.
Nun will sie Gewissheit:
Sarah macht für Nathalie
einen DNA-Test in Sri Lanka.
Ich hatte schon das Gefühl,
dass diese Frau meine Mutter ist,
denn es war sehr emotional.
Sie weinte und sagte,
sie sei so froh, uns wiederzusehen.
Diese Frau
hat tatsächlich zwei Kinder
zur Adoption freigegeben,
einen Jungen und ein Mädchen.
Aber da bleibt ein kleiner Zweifel,
ob sie wirklich
meine leibliche Mutter ist.
Sarah macht sich also
mit einem Dolmetscher auf den Weg
in das kleine, arme Dorf
im Norden Colombos.
Sie trifft hier die Frau,
die Nathalies Mutter sein soll.
(Dolmetscher) She's happy. Come in.
- Okay. Thank you.
In diesem Brief hat sie gefragt,
ob Sie einverstanden sind
mit einem DNA-Test.
Sie sagt, sie würde das gerne tun.
Sie sagt, weil es ihre Kinder seien,
möchte sie das gerne tun.
Fünf Wochen wird es dauern,
bis das Testresultat vorliegt.
Now, she can take one.
(Nathalie) Ich hoffe wirklich,
dass ich nach all den Jahren
nun die Bestätigung bekomme.
Denn wenn nicht,
beginne ich wieder bei Null.
Das würde bedeuten, dass
all meine Papiere gefälscht sind,
dass die Fotos,
die ich meinen Kindern gezeigt habe,
als sie Fragen stellten,
gar nicht mich als Baby zeigen.
Es gelingt sogar,
in diesem abgelegenen Dorf
den Kontakt in die Schweiz
herzustellen.
Hallo, meine Tochter.
- She's speaking to you.
(Nathalie) Yeah, hello!
- Hello, my daughter.
Hallo, Mama!
Sie möchte Sie gerne sehen -
und v.a. Ihre Kinder.
* Sie spricht tamilisch. *
Sie sagt, es sei schön,
Ihre Stimme zu hören.
Thank you!
Sie möchte Sie gerne sehen.
* Sie spricht tamilisch. *
Sie hat mehrmals betont,
dass sie kein Geld bekommen hat,
als sie euch beide weggegeben hat.
Sie hat mehrmals gesagt:
"Ich habe meine Kinder
nicht verkauft."
Look!
Die Frau erklärt im Gespräch,
dass sie damals allein und mittellos
krank geworden sei.
Im Spital hat eine Krankenschwester,
die in Kontakt war
mit Dawn da Silvas Organisation,
sie überredet, ihre Kinder abzugeben.
Ich habe erfahren, dass sie uns
zwar freiwillig abgegeben hat,
aber dass doch
ein gewisser Druck da war.
Das macht einen grossen Unterschied,
dass sie offenbar
nicht genau wusste, was sie tat.
V.a. rechnete sie damit,
uns wiederzusehen.
Heute bin ich ja selbst Mutter
und kann mir gar nicht vorstellen,
wie das für sie gewesen sein muss.
Denken Sie, dass man ihr nicht genau
erklärt hat, was das beinhaltet?
Offensichtlich nicht.
Man hat ihr nicht erklärt,
was eine Adoption bedeutet.
Sie rechnete damit,
uns wiederzusehen.
Sie war danach ein Jahr lang
in einer psychiatrischen Klinik,
und erst dort hat sie begriffen,
was sie getan hatte.
Die adoptierten Kinder
sind nicht die einzigen,
die ihre Familien
wiederfinden wollen.
Auch Mütter
suchen nach ihren Kindern,
die in den 80er-Jahren
als Babys adoptiert wurden.
Doch das Thema
bleibt ein Tabu in Sri Lanka.
Die Behörden helfen den Frauen nicht
und DNA-Tests
sind für sie nicht bezahlbar.
Der Verein von Sarah und Olivia
hat eine Warteliste
von etwa 100 Frauen.
Sri-lankische Frauen
können es sich nicht leisten,
einen DNA-Test zu machen.
Unsere Arbeit und
die Arbeit von anderen Adoptierten
ist also sehr wichtig.
Wir sind noch am Anfang:
Wir haben mit elf DNA-Kits begonnen,
und es gibt 11'000 Adoptierte
auf der ganzen Welt.
Es gibt also noch viel zu tun,
aber man muss ja irgendwo anfangen.
Mit diesen Stäbchen werden Hautzellen
für den DNA-Test entnommen.
Die Resultate werden anschliessend
an eine internationale Datenbank
gegeben.
Die Frauen hoffen,
dass ihre Kinder sie ebenfalls suchen
und dass sie sich über die Datenbank
dank übereinstimmender DNA finden.
Es sieht so aus, als ob diese Mütter
ihre Kinder
freiwillig abgegeben haben.
Aber man ist sich
vielleicht nicht bewusst,
unter welchem Druck
die Mütter standen:
Entweder wurden die Kinder
ihnen legal weggenommen
oder sie wurden dazu gezwungen,
die Kinder abzugeben,
oder die eigene Familie
hat Druck ausgeübt.
Sie konnten sehr wenig entscheiden -
um nicht zu sagen gar nichts.
Diese Frau erzählt,
dass sie sehr jung geheiratet hat,
gegen den Willen ihrer Eltern.
Sie war schwanger,
als ihr Mann sie verliess.
Ihre Familie zwang sie,
ihr Baby wegzugeben.
Ich suche seit etwa 18 Jahren,
ich weiss es nicht mehr ganz genau.
Sie kam am 15. Juni 1977
in der Castle Maternity
in Colombo zur Welt,
sie heisst Anusha Kumari.
Ich dachte damals,
auch wenn ich sie weggebe,
dass ich sie zu einem späteren
Zeitpunkt wiedersehen würde.
Ich war völlig hilflos.
Ich möchte mein Kind wiedersehen,
bevor ich sterbe.
Um herauszufinden,
wer ihre Papiere gefälscht hat,
verfolgt Olivia
noch eine andere Spur:
Sie will Dawn da Silva finden,
die Vermittlerin,
welche ihre Adoption organisiert hat.
Die Frau ist seit
mehreren Jahrzehnten verschwunden,
Gerüchten zufolge soll sie
in Kalifornien oder Australien leben.
Im Telefonbuch
finden wir eine Dawn da Silva.
Die Adresse führt uns
in eine bessere Gegend von Colombo.
Eine Nachbarin zeigt uns,
welches Haus.
Wir können es selbst nicht fassen,
als wir sie
in ihrem Garten antreffen.
Wir erkennen sie sofort.
Zuerst streitet sie ab,
Dawn da Silva zu sein.
Doch als wir sie mit den Dokumenten
konfrontieren, gibt sie es zu.
Wir improvisieren
und filmen mit unseren Handys.
Dawn da Silva sagt,
dass sie keine Unterlagen
aus jener Zeit mehr besitzt.
Sie erinnern sich nicht an die Namen?
- Nein.
Und Sie haben keine Unterlagen mehr?
Kein Archiv?
Nein.
Sie haben gar keine Papiere
aus der Zeit, gar nichts?
Nein.
Wir konfrontieren sie mit Fotos
und Briefen, die sie verschickt hat.
Aber sie erinnert sich an kein Baby,
das durch sie vermittelt wurde.
Weder an Olivia noch an Sandy
noch an Nathalie, an niemanden.
Mein ganzes Leben lang dachte ich,
Sie seien die Anwältin,
welche meine Adoption durchführte
und mich
meiner Mutter weggenommen hatte.
Nein, das ist nicht meine Schuld.
Verstehen Sie, dass es für diese
Kinder heute sehr belastend ist,
dass sie ihre leiblichen Eltern
nicht finden können?
Das verstehe ich.
Aber ich habe die Kinder und ihre
Geburtsurkunden nicht ausgesucht,
ich weiss nichts darüber.
Ich habe sie nur
ins Büro von Herrn Pereira gebracht,
und dann mussten die Eltern
vor einem Anwalt unterschreiben
und das war's.
Aber Sie haben nie
die biologischen Mütter getroffen,
die ihre Kinder
zur Adoption freigaben?
Nein,
die kamen immer mit den Vermittlern.
Es gab aber Frauen,
die nicht die Mütter waren,
die aber die Papiere unterzeichneten.
Das müssen Sie die Vermittler
fragen, sie haben alles gemacht.
Aber Sie, Sie hatten doch
auch Schauspielmütter.
Nein, ich hatte damit nichts zu tun,
mit den Adoptionen.
Die Diskussion wird immer surrealer.
Dawn da Silva behauptet,
ihre Verhaftung 1987
sei ein abgekartetes Spiel gewesen.
Die Rache
eines eifersüchtigen Ex-Mannes.
Das war alles erfunden?
Gab es denn keine Babyfarmen?
Ich wurde
vom Generalstaatsanwalt entlastet,
dadurch bekam ich mein Visum und
ging nach Australien und in die USA,
denn ich hatte nichts damit zu tun,
ich hatte nur übersetzt
und die Reise organisiert,
sonst weiss ich nichts.
Sie haben keine Babyfarm
in Wadduwa betrieben?
Nein, das ist alles erfunden.
- Erfunden also.
Waren Sie denn nicht im Gefängnis?
- Für kurze Zeit, ja.
Wie lange?
- Etwa eine Woche.
Eine Woche und dann kamen Sie raus?
- Ja.
Artikeln aus dieser Zeit zufolge
ist es ihr
aufgrund eines Verfahrensfehlers
gelungen, das Gefängnis zu umgehen.
Danach ist sie in die USA geflüchtet.
Und sie scheint nichts zu bereuen.
Was würden Sie denn
all diesen Kindern und Babys sagen?
Die sind doch dort sicher glücklich,
oder?
Ich denke, einige
wären sonst im Abfall gelandet.
Danach habe ich
viele solche Sachen gesehen.
Im Abfall gelandet in Sri Lanka?
- Ja.
Sie denken, Sie hätten sie
vor einem schlimmen Leben
in Sri Lanka gerettet?
- Genau.
Schmerzhafte Worte für Olivia.
Viele Mütter sind sehr traurig,
dass sie ihre Kinder verloren haben.
Alles, was sie wollen, ist,
ihre Kinder zu finden,
bevor sie sterben.
Tut Ihnen das nicht leid?
Ich denke schon.
Aber Sie haben doch sicher
ein besseres Leben gehabt
als in Sri Lanka?
Ich weiss nicht,
wie mein Leben hier verlaufen wäre,
aber ich wäre
bei meiner Mutter gewesen.
Mein ganzes Leben lang
habe ich meine Mutter vermisst,
das ist sehr traurig für mich.
- Ich verstehe.
Sind Sie wirklich sicher, dass Sie
sich nicht an Olivia Ramya erinnern?
Was möchten Sie ihr gerne sagen?
Ich hoffe,
dass sie ihre Mutter findet.
Okay, thank you very much.
Am nächsten Tag
schickt uns Dawn da Silva eine E-Mail
mit den Namen der Vermittler.
Doch die meisten
sind bereits gestorben,
es gibt keine Spur mehr,
die wir weiterverfolgen könnten.
Sie bedroht uns
und verbietet uns, wiederzukommen.
Wir versuchen also,
sie per Telefon zu erreichen,
aber ihre Nummer
ist nicht mehr gültig.
Fünf Wochen später treffen wir
Nathalie in Romont wieder.
Sie hat das Resultat
ihres DNA-Tests erhalten.
Er ist positiv - sie hat
ihre leibliche Mutter gefunden.
Zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben haben
sich meine Schultern entspannt,
ich habe weniger Probleme mit der
Atmung, auch mit der Verdauung.
Ich glaube,
das spielt alles zusammen.
Denn ohne
dass man sich dessen bewusst ist -
der Körper erinnert sich,
und da löste sich plötzlich
eine enorme Anspannung.
Ich bin sehr dankbar,
denn ich kenne andere Personen,
die ihre leibliche Mutter
ebenfalls lange suchten
und dann am Ende
einen negativen Bescheid bekamen.
Das ist extrem hart.
Ich weiss,
was für ein Glück ich hatte.
Und meine Kinder
sind nun in einem Alter,
in dem sie anfangen,
mir Fragen zu stellen.
Ich habe immer ein bisschen
gezögert, ihnen zu antworten,
weil ich nicht sicher war.
Das hat sich nun geändert.
Nun kann ich ihnen sagen,
dass wir dorthin fliegen können,
wenn sie das möchten.
Ich finde das sehr wichtig,
dass sie es wissen
und dass sie das
nicht durchmachen müssen,
diese Recherchearbeit,
all die offenen Fragen.
Sie werden Antworten haben, und das
ist sehr wichtig für ihre Identität.
Olivia sucht weiter.
Sie fühlt sich gut in Sri Lanka
und möchte so oft wie möglich
hierher zurückkehren.
Aber anders als Sarah und Nathalie
plant sie im Moment
keine eigene Familie.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich Kinder haben werde.
Ich weiss,
dass es für einige sehr heilsam war,
neue Wurzeln zu schlagen.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht bereit,
Mutter zu sein.
Denn zuerst muss ich mich noch um
das kleine, verletzte Kind kümmern,
das immer noch in mir drin ist.
Salut!
- Salut!
Ca va?
- Bien, et toi?
Diesen Schmerz, das Gefühl,
entwurzelt worden zu sein,
trägt auch Sarah mit sich.
Aber sie bereut es nicht, ihre
Vergangenheit aufgerollt zu haben.
Im Alltag findet sie Trost
in ihrem Beruf als Hebamme.
Im Alter von zwölf Jahren
wusste ich,
dass dies mein Beruf werden sollte.
Rückblickend denke ich heute,
dass die Begleitung
der werdenden Mütter und ihrer Babys
sehr heilsam für mich war.
Für mich
ist das immer noch ein Geheimnis,
diese Mutter-Baby-Beziehung.
Aber Sie haben noch Hoffnung,
Ihre leibliche Mutter zu finden?
Ja, ich habe noch Hoffnung.
Aber man muss
eine gute Balance finden,
damit es nicht zur Obsession wird.
Ich habe ja mein Leben,
meine Familie, meine Kinder hier.
Auf der anderen Seite:
Wie soll man jemals aufhören,
seine Familie zu suchen?
Ich denke, die Hoffnung
wird bis zuletzt bleiben.